because she's she's twisting it and
making it sound as if you were so
unattractive that nobody did she get a
dirty wine did somebody grab on her so
these are things that she sees that she
knows happening and she's trying to turn
it to take the piss out of you to say
you are so unattractive that people
didn't do that so she knows what happens
at carnival so why would you go she's
saying what happens okay and that's the
other thing they always that's always
their go-to not pretty enough okay
no the only thing that happened was I
was um walking back and like there was
this crowd and someone got kind of close
to me but I feel like he kind of clocked
that I was not I was like I swear to God
you grabbed me we're gonna have problems
you can have that look you can leave it
you can deal with it and kind of was the
kind of friendly place that if you give
someone like you don't smile and say hi
to everyone if you know that somebody's
getting too friendly a look is enough
yeah sometimes they can tell by your
stance that you're not a carnival person
or you're just a visitor yeah especially
by the way you're dressed but she's she
just said it oh because she's making
that old Carnival was so innocent but
did you get the dirty wine you know so
she knows what happens because she's got
she's good looking I have to get a dirty
one because you know all the men are
grabbing her body don't forget she's
that attractive you're there shaking up
and that's ignorance and grips that's
ignorance and it's offensive to the
Caribbean culture
you can't tell me what's offensive to
the Caribbean culture you're not
Caribbean sorry you're not Caribbean so
can you tell me what's offensive to
Caribbean culture
it's offensive young people no grabbed
yeah but most people get them
different times
but grannies be getting grabbed me as
well with their families
everyone's having a conversation like
this we're always talking about the
majority not the minority yeah tell them
again always talking about that you
can't so the majority I know what I see
at carnival yeah and every man there
knows what they say it is
me I'm not the majority no no but then
when she said that all you have to say
is that now I went there and I went home
you didn't think I didn't say it she
didn't oh why are you always adding your
little like yeah
no no she did she had she did if I said
to her if I said to her I lived on that
book growth she was like oh don't tell
us extra bits now you didn't see that
though because I did I did that I did
today no she cut me up if you saw it
nobody cut you up you said that you
lived on that book Grove and you just
went down the road to watch Carnival you
didn't mention nothing about no jerk
chicken oh I just grabbed jerk chicken
who's gonna go to Carnival grab jerk
chicken and go back home come on I've
had friends that lived on Redbook Grove
we stayed in front of the house and
watched the carnival go by you didn't
say that all of a sudden you're living
in a gator community and you popped out
you went to get your chicken and come
back you're a liar yeah and one thing
she does as well she'll be like don't
talk I'm talking oh I'm sorry do you
know what and then that's what the men
should have said to you because that's
what you've done all that time so
perhaps you would have said stop as a
pearl said stop stop stop stop can you
stop talking when I'm talking and look
what you're doing to the men look what
you are doing to the men you haven't
stopped doing that
yeah [ __ ] come on mine they're so
traditional come on mine you haven't got
one you've really said you should come
on mine who's the [ __ ] now [ __ ]
she gave me enough night time is she
stupid no we didn't give you enough mic
time you took it no one could shut you
up you took the night time that when you
come on a show she's gonna shut you down
because you gave her enough my time
you're stupid because you gave her
enough my time
respect means not over talking the host
so if you keep over talking the host
they're quite having their right to tell
you stop stop stop stop stop and if you
don't stop then say excuse me but can
you shut up you don't overtalk the house
that's all you've done all you've done
since you've been on their podcast to
say listen I'm talking now they're the
holes and it's their shoes
you might have cut you up but she didn't
say shut up she said stop talking it's
my podcast
that was so rude of you stop talking
it's my podcast it was because you both
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up both of you
and on top of that you want me to
explain myself then you tell me stop but
someone I gave you plenty of time to
explain it is not my fault because you
saved yourself you can do a bigger and
bigger hole she contradicted herself she
said that you gave her a lot of air time
you didn't give it to her she took it
did say you keep interrupting people pal
that person has sent at least yeah now
out of all the comments she found one
person one person that said oh you know
you were doing it as well Pearl you know
one person and that's what she's going
with it you wouldn't know but if you
want to go through the trouble of
starting a podcast getting a producer
getting an editor um putting a bunch of
chairs together buying a bunch of
equipment
um hiring a bunch of people and you want
to have someone and you want to
interrupt me on your show you can yeah
it's your show that's fine
uh but then had the rest of our cult
following she said I was too
argumentative at every point I was
making was just to be argument you never
said she was argumentative because she
was talking dumb she was just arguing
for everybody said that about she was
just being she was just oh how can you
not know what a woman is of course I'm
gonna argue you are a woman you came on
the air and said you bleed three times a
month look it look it look here I I do
think you're arguing just to argue if
you can't acknowledge a man versus a
woman call me old-fashioned call me
crazy but yeah yeah I stand on that call
me call me crazy if and a lot of women
that go on her podcast they all have the
same experience where are they I do
think that she's I'm sorry wait hold on
anti-woman and I think especially
um if like ethnic women
okay so you're gonna insinuate that I'm
sexist and a racist and then invite me
to go on your podcast but but Auntie I'm
so sexist and racist why why would they
invite me on their podcast I don't want
to racism I I certainly wouldn't want
myself doing a show about races
and look at look at the girl in the
middle who doesn't like the drama and
doesn't want to be a part of it she's
super happy she's enjoying it and all
these girls have the same experience
there is a a good chunk than in the
London hate group it's not just them
there's there's a couple there's like
two that threaten to beat me up
um and they come on the show they didn't
have a good experience but here's the
thing like you meet people in life half
of them aren't gonna like you that just
happens that's part of life you think
all the people that come on your show
like you no come on and and this is the
thing it's like so and and there's a
bunch of people there's a bunch of
people that love the show we have a
whole community of people that that are
like friends because of the show no
we're not gonna go you know we're not
gonna say it's in the majority but most
people do like you the majority of
people like her and if you don't like
Pearl why the hell are you following it
if you don't like her why are you coming
on the show if you don't like her why do
you want us to come on your low
prophetic show why
I refuse to go on a show with a woman no
I can't say that
because you don't know what a woman is
a real thing
somebody who believes three times a
month I can't go on a show and you don't
know what a woman is come on
and you still have Modern Woman she is
you will see an ethnic woman there you
will see it it's better than mine I was
doing the recruitment yeah so yeah I'm
coming for you now they're blaming him
now they blaming him before they were
saying that you brought them onto the
show and there they can see that we
don't know who's coming onto the show
Eddie recruited them
it included them but they approached
Eddie we would like to go on this show
Eddie said okay or vice versa would you
like to go on this show they said yes
how is that Pearl's full when we tell
you that we do not know who's it's very
rare you might get the odd one like
Davina or somebody yeah but occasionally
like one or two or I might invite you
but it's always like a regulars that I'm
friends with that I'll just like last
minute they'll want to come on but I
don't know I don't know who's coming 90
of the time you think I got time to go
through all these profiles at four days
a week oh God you got me [ __ ] up you
messed it up no it wasn't really hurt
nah you messed up it just turns out you
know I was gonna cut you off for that it
just turns out yeah
wow
I literally I was gonna then I thought
you know what it is I'm obviously I made
connections with like
um Cheryl Lynn Cheryl Lynn do you know
Range Rover mom yeah yeah and I've made
a connection with other women like and I
thought you know what it's good to come
out of it other women that are crazy
crazy I don't know how these people are
personally but like oh they're crazy
without like them she's got nothing
disclaimer she has nothing to do with
Range Rover please don't call a Range
Rover mom because Range Rover does not
like him
okay
she's the one that went to that when
they were protesting she pushed one of
them with her car because she had to get
her kids to school and she actually did
the protesting I'm gonna sit in the
streets and include himself I only found
out the other day when somebody watched
this and told me who she was but I don't
know who she is you don't want to know
she's has she been on the show no she's
got her own podcast but it's for women
like them oh they're craziest yeah
um
and then she said she's gonna cut any
off for inviting her on the show
like what I would say here is that when
it comes to like when Pearl and not
speaking and talking about statistics
like you sound like a you sound pick me
you sound like I'm gonna pick me I'm not
like shame and Tokyo and need to be
right he a man can't have an opinion
without you cutting him off or insulting
him that's how that's how she is sexist
I'm gonna just say this now she is she
is sexist and misogynistic or misandras
misandrist I know my words
listen I don't show there's no one right
now it would be mad
when you're replying you can't reply
with feelings why don't you come back
with a statistic I love their accents
calming them
yeah then do a podcast you know when you
said you want to travel they said
Birmingham oh is that who it was about
half an hour from me oh okay okay okay
maybe I will I mean those this is what
you say well actually this kind of woman
does this and does this don't say oh
well I feel like that's that's not oh
this is
my opinion
something one thing people need to
realize about statistics it's not every
single goddamn person on the world hold
up let me land we know what's the man on
the left when she's trying to land
as a politics student who had to use
statistics in what I've argued right
I've had to even manipulate my own
statistics to suit a certain agenda
right hold up let me land now hold up
when you're looking at UK statistics my
mother has never answered any of these
questions right most of our mothers
haven't these statistics hold up
standing is turbulence
is gonna fall down he's saying the
turbulence on the landing and the oxygen
mask is going to fall down
into a certain demographic of people
right my reality especially like just
say my friendship groups Asian African
people very Asian African like we're
first gen most of us are very strong
faith in not Christianity stop you're
not you would be with your husband
the job is still in your face and leave
your husband or looking at getting
divorced I'm saying 99.9 would never
cheat because that's we Fair God right
hold up that's my she never cheat but
she was willing to concern you having
letting her husband have two wives
reality of my statistics right that
statistic is still quite important but
you're telling me the UK women will
cheat that's not that's that's anecdote
weeks no no no no but I could do it I
could quantify it then do it but this is
what I'm saying I can quantify it no
one's just had time to quantify it so
the statistics that's like for example
the one that you used about credit
consumer credit where I've worked as a
financial investigator Consumer Credit
who does it impact the most it's not
ethnic women it's not just credit it's
women women on two-thirds of Consumer
Debt we also own the majority of student
debt
um and we also are higher on default for
like paying rent we're higher on default
for credit cards we're higher um we
spend more even though we make less like
it's multiple stats it's not just one
usually it's because those countries
don't have policies it's usually a
policy now what should you try to say is
that you're talking about like UCO
America and what she wants you to do she
wants to take all the black people out
of it should I list all like every
country in the world and go through
let's say Antarctica there's not many
people and that's what she wants Randy
women of the UK English women just
saying yeah my mom has never said it's
not credit right yeah so you're
statistic about single moms on credit
though yeah they're not our kind of
women
so what I'm saying is when a woman
especially a woman who's a single mum
depends on consumer credit and making
them a lot of them come who've got drug
addictions they've got other significant
conditions that's a lot of rubbish
because a lot of single parents can't
even get credit you can't get credit
she's making it sound like you can just
go and get credit
it's like the working people that are
getting the credit it's very rare that
but then you might go to loan sharks and
stuff like that but she's talking
rubbish there are impacting them right
bad decisions they make it but they've
got they might come from severe like God
knows what else yeah but they make
stupid decisions based on their
lifestyle okay yeah that that's that's
true she made a stupid decision that's
true women do make stupid decisions
based on their lifestyle they spend more
even though they make less look it and
you cannot blame the world for you
making dumb decisions because of your
trauma
men don't do this and many I would argue
that men experience more trauma than
women the world is very hard for men and
that's what a lot of women don't
understand we are born with beauty and
youth and that goes away at some point
and but the thing is like the world is
here to protect you like men are always
looking to protect women and they have
this innate like thing they're nicer to
you because you're a woman and and the
thing is like women we will never know
what it is like to be a man and to be
treated like a man and they don't even
make excuses for this [ __ ]
there's black and Asian women that are
single mothers and their culture and
Faith have made them different
population in the UK is black and F or
only 12.
statistics where should you get those
statistics from She's shouting at
numbers no no this is against stats
that's right and I don't disagree what
you're saying yeah it represents such a
small fraction of the entire exactly
that it's irrelevant to the main topic
but that doesn't take but
the fact that there are women so when
I'm talking about my reality that's
because my reality of women are my
statistics of women I don't go for the
UK statistics I go for what my women are
like yeah but that's what I mean there's
a lot of my yeah but you came on my
podcast why would I why would I talk
about why why would I talk about what
she said she's Bangladesh Bangladesh e
women on a show in the UK run by an
American
and because of you guys I'm going to
quantify it so women ethnic women come
out do the surveys
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible